If we know the position x of
t of an object as a function
of time, we can
use differentiation
to calculate its velocity
and its acceleration
at later times.
Essentially, by taking the
derivatives of the position,
we know everything there is
to know about the motion.
Sometimes, however, we'll want
to go in the other direction.
We'll have the acceleration
as a function of time
and we'll want to find the
velocity as a function of time,
or the position as
a function of time.
We'll use a technique
called integration,
and let's see how that works.
To begin with, suppose we
have a constant acceleration.
So our acceleration a of
t is some constant a 0.
In that case, we know that
this constant acceleration can
be written as the
change in velocity
delta v over some
time interval delta t,
and therefore that the change in
velocity delta v over some time
interval delta t
can just be written
as a 0 acceleration, the
constant acceleration,
times the elapsed time delta t.
And we can see this
graphically if I
plot acceleration versus time.
Here is my constant
acceleration a 0.
Let's say this is
time 0 and here is
the time delta t, the change
in velocity, a 0 times delta t,
is just the area of this
box, that box being defined
by the time interval
0 to delta t,
and it's the area
under the curve, a 0.
So if we know the
velocity at time 0
and we know the constant
acceleration a 0,
we can calculate the velocity
at any later time in this way,
because the change in velocity
from that initial velocity
is given by a 0 times delta t.
Now let's consider a slightly
more complicated example.
Suppose the acceleration
isn't constant
but is changing linearly.
So for a linearly
changing acceleration,
I can draw this
graphically as well.
Here's acceleration.
This is time equals 0.
Suppose the acceleration
is increasing linearly,
and I'll call this time delta t.
This is a of t.
Note that we can define
an average acceleration
over the interval
from 0 to delta t.
The average acceleration
is the change
in velocity over
the elapsed time.
That average acceleration
will look something like that.
And so then the change
in velocity, delta v,
is equal to the
average acceleration
times the elapsed time.
And this time, notice from
the diagram this product
is actually the area of this
trapezoid that's basically
the area under the a
of t function going
from 0 to delta t.
We've calculated it sort of as
a rectangular area involving
the average acceleration,
but that's also
equal to the area under the time
changing acceleration function.
So this is, again,
the area under a of t
over the time interval delta t.
Now let's consider a more
generally changing acceleration
as a function of time.
So let me plot this.
So suppose we have just some
general function-- I'll draw it
like this-- which
is our acceleration
as a function of time.
The change in
velocity will still
be the area under the curve
a of t over the time interval
we're interested in.
So let's suppose we want
to go from this time
here-- I'll call it t
sub a-- and my ending
time will be t sub b.
So we're interested
in figuring out
what the area under this curve
is over the interval from t sub
a to t sub b.
We can estimate
this by breaking up
the interval into a bunch
of little rectangle.
Suppose I break this up
into n rectangles just
under this curve.
And so this is 1, 2, 3,
4, et cetera, up to n.
And with each one, because
this is a curved graph,
I can't get the rectangle to fit
exactly so a little bit of it
will stick out at
the top of each one.
I'm not going to go through
that for all of these,
but you get the idea.
I'll fit these rectangles
as well as I can.
The narrower I make
the rectangles,
the more easily I can
fit them under the curve.
For each strip, for
each rectangular strip,
let's say from over box
1 from here to here,
the change in velocity is
equal to the average velocity
over that time interval
times the width
of that rectangle, delta t.
So that's the area of the strip.
Essentially what we're
saying is that if we
make the rectangles
narrow enough,
we can treat the acceleration,
the curve of the acceleration,
as roughly constant
over that interval.
And we can make n
as big as we need
to to make those rectangles
very, very narrow.
So in that case, we can estimate
the total change in velocity
from time t sub
a to time t sub b
by adding up the area of all
of these rectangular strips.
So in that case, we write that.
The change in velocity--
so I'll say v sub
b minus v sub a-- that's
the change of velocity going
from time a to time b--
is equal to the sum,
as j goes from 1 to n, of the
area of each of these strips.
And so we want the acceleration
at the i-th rectangle,
so that's a of t sub j times
the width of the strip.
Each strip has the same width.
We'll just call that delta t.
And that's the area of n strips.
Now for a finite--
I really should
write this as
approximately equal to--
because for a finite number
of rectangular strips,
this is just an approximation,
because as I mentioned,
the rectangles don't
exactly fit under the curve.
They can't because the rectangle
doesn't have a curved top,
but the function is curved.
But the narrower I
make the rectangles,
or equivalently,
the larger I make n,
the better the
approximation will be.
So what I want to do is go to
the limit of an infinite number
of rectangles, or
equivalently, the limit
of infinitesimally
narrow strips.
I want delta t to go to 0.
So to make this exact,
what I would write
is that the change in
velocity from time a to time b
is equal to the limit of
the sum from j equals 1 to n
of the acceleration at time t
sub j subject times delta t.
And we want to evaluate that
limit as delta t goes to 0,
or equivalently, as n,
the number of rectangles,
goes to infinity.
Now this is a very
important expression,
and we have a special
way of writing it.
We can also write
it as an integral.
So we write it as the
integral of the function
a of t dt evaluated from
time equals t sub a to time
equals t sub b.
And this is the area under the
a of t curve, the exact area--
not the approximate area, but
the exact area under the a
of t curve over the interval
from t of a to t of b.
This limiting sum
that we've written
this way on the right-hand side
is called the definite integral
of a of t.
And it's related to the
process of integration
that you've learned
about in calculus,
which is the inverse of taking
the derivative, the inverse
of differentiation.
I want to take a moment to
summarize the basic principles
of integration from calculus.
Let's begin by
considering a function
g of x with some derivative.
So consider a function g of x.
And let's assume it's a
well-behaved function, by which
I mean that it's continuous
and differentiable
over the interval that
we're interested in.
So consider g of x
with a derivative.
So dg dx equal to
another function,
which I'll call f of x.
Now note that if I add
a constant to g of x,
I'll still get the
same derivative.
So note that the
derivative with respect
to x of g of x plus
a constant is still
equal to the same
function f of x.
And this is because of the
derivative of a constant
is equal to 0.
Now, suppose I want to
invert this process.
Then I can write that
the antiderivative
of f of x, the
antiderivative of f
of x, which I'll write as
the integral of f of x, dx,
is equal to g of
x plus a constant.
The left-hand side of this we
call an indefinite integral.
And so we see that if
the derivative of g of x
is f of x plus a concert,
the antiderivative of f of x
is g of x plus a constant.
And that can be any
arbitrary constant.
Now in calculus, one
learns how to calculate
the indefinite integral of
various functions, polynomials,
trigonometric functions,
logarithmic functions, et
cetera.
Calculus also shows us how to
compute the definite integral.
So the definite integral,
the integral of f of x, dx,
evaluated from x
equals a to x equals b.
So this is the definite
integral computed
over some interval that is
equal to the antiderivative at x
equals b minus the
antiderivative evaluated
at x equals a.
And this turns out to be
the area under the curve
f of x in the interval between
x equals a and x equals b.
Now notice that there
is no arbitrary constant
in the definite integral.
In the indefinite integral,
we have an arbitrary constant,
but in the definite integral,
that arbitrary constant
is determined by setting
the integration limits.
So there's no
arbitrary constant.
We just have this difference.
And so just to see
this graphically,
if I plot my function
f of x and suppose
this is x equals a and
this is x equals b,
this definite
integral represents
the area under the curve f of
x in the interval from x equals
a to x equals b.
So calculus tells us how
to solve this area problem,
how to compute a
definite integral,
from the antiderivative
that you get
from indefinite integration.
And so this same
technique tells us
how to determine the velocity
from the acceleration,
since we saw that that
was equivalent to an area
under the curve problem.
So to come back to
the motion of objects,
we've shown that the change
in velocity of an object
can be written as the definite
integral of the acceleration.
So just to write that
a little bit more
formally first with
a plot, if this
is my acceleration as
a function of time,
we know that the time
derivative of the velocity
is equal to the acceleration
as a function of time.
I can rewrite that as the
differential dv is equal to a
of t times the differential dt.
And so then I can integrate
both sides of this equation
by writing the
integral over dv is
equal to the integral of the
acceleration of a of t dt.
And I can go from time
equals some initial time t 0
to time equal to
some later time t sub
1 on the right-hand side to
make a definite integral.
And then on the left-hand
side the corresponding limits
are the velocity
at time 0-- I'll
call that v 0-- and the velocity
at time 1, which I'll call v1.
So just to be clear,
I'm assuming here
that v 0 is equal to the
velocity at time t 0,
and v1 is equal to the
velocity at time t sub 1.
So this is the integral of a
constant over an interval of v.
This is an interval of the
acceleration over the time
interval in t.
And so the left-hand side--
this is just v1 minus v 0.
And the right-hand side,
without specifying a of t,
I can't actually
evaluate this integral.
I can't specify what the
antiderivative of a of t
is unless I tell you what
the function a of t is.
So we'll just have to leave
it in terms of an integral.
And so that's just the
integral of a of t dt from t
equals t 0 to t equals t sub 1.
So again, this shows
us that the change
in the velocity from time
t 0 to a later time t1
is equal to the
definite integral of a
of t over that integral.
I can rewrite this in terms
of what the velocity is
at some later time, t1, by
writing the velocity at t1
is equal to v 0 plus the
integral of a of t dt from t
equals t 0 to t equals t1.
Note that T1 is just any
later time after time t
0, where we have the
initial velocity.
So a more convenient way
of writing this function
might be to write the
velocity as a function
of some later time t.
So suppose I were to do that.
I'll just rewrite this
equation replacing t1
with an arbitrary time t.
So I have that v
of t is equal to v
0 plus the integral of a of t dt
from t equals t0 to t equals t.
Now there is
something funny here,
because I have t in the
integration variable here.
But I have t as one
of my limits here as
well, whereas if I look
at this expression here,
there's a difference between
the t in the integration
variable and the limit t1.
They actually represent
different things.
So to keep track of that, the
notation that we generally
use in physics is to call this
integration variable t prime
and so we write this
acceleration of t prime,
dt prime, with the time
t prime going from t 0
to some later time t.
Now one has to be cautious here.
In some fields that
prime on a variable
is used to denote a
derivative, a differentiation.
That's not what it means here.
I'm writing t prime
just to distinguish it
from the specific later
time t that I want
to calculate the velocity at.
And it's worth thinking about
what this expression means.
This equation is identical
to this earlier equation
that we derived except
for a change in notation.
And so let's think about
what that notation means.
t prime here is the
integration variable.
It's a placeholder.
Remember, the integral
here, the definite integral,
represents an infinite sum,
an infinite sum of rectangles
between a time t 0
and a later time t.
And that variable t prime--
actually, what I should do now
is I should call this t prime.
This variable t prime is taking
every value from t 0 to t.
So t prime is representing
the running time variable
for all of our strips
that we're adding up
over this definite integral.
So it's a placeholder variable.
We sometimes call
it a dummy variable.
It's just a placeholder
to represent time,
whereas t, the t in the
limit here without the prime,
represents a specific
choice of later time,
some later time t where we
want to calculate the velocity.
So we know the velocity
at some initial time t 0.
We'd like to know the velocity
at some specific later time t.
And to compute that, we
have to integrate over
all times running from t 0 to t.
And that running
integration variable
we represent as t prime
just to distinguish it
from the specific time
t that we are trying
to compute the velocity for.
So now in just the
same way that we've
obtained the velocity by
integrating the acceleration,
we can integrate again.
We can integrate the velocity
to calculate the position.
So given v of t, we can show
that the position at time t
is equal to the
position at time t
0 plus the integral of
the velocity as a function
of time-- I'll write
this as t prime-- dt
prime going from t prime
equals t 0 to t prime equals t.
So this is exactly analogous
to how we computed velocity
from acceleration.
By integrating a second
time, we can go from velocity
to position.
So once we know the
acceleration a of t,
we can use integration to
compute the velocity v of t
if we know the velocity
at some initial time t 0.
And we can also compute
the position x of t
if we know the initial
position at time t 0, x 0.
So we see that given
the acceleration,
we can recover the
velocity and the position.
And as it happens, from
Newton's Second Law,
if we know the forces
acting on an object,
that gives us the
ability to compute
what the acceleration is.
And then given the
acceleration, we
can use integration to find
the velocity and the position.